le dark circus est en ville un cirque où
chaque numéro est une mise en péril un
accident qu'on croirait presque
programmé dac circus est créée en live
par deux magiciens romain brémond et
jean baptiste mallet une oeuvre à 90% au
noir et blanc
comment on passe de la tristesse à la
joie
si on n'a jamais été triste on sait pas
ce que c'est que ces joyeux et donc
voilà il ya quelque chose qui est de cet
ordre là dans le rapport et puis après
il ya énormément de messages qu'on a qui
sont qui sont dedans c'est un compte
donc il ya plusieurs niveaux de lecture
et c'est pour ça que c'est des
spectacles qui s'adresse aussi à toutes
et à tous selon les âges des cultures
des gens qui c'est la première fois
qu'il mettait dans un théâtre comme des
gens qui sont abonnés à des scènes
nationales
des prouesses techniques et artistiques
qui illustrent au plus près une histoire
originale de pef l'auteur du célèbre
prince de motordu on a mis deux ans pour
créer ce spectacle c'est ce qu'on met
généralement pour créer des spectacles à
c'est notre quatrième et
c'est long parce que on fait tout à 2 2
la composition des morceaux à la
construction des décors et des
marionnettes à la conception de dessins
et de comment on va amener l'histoire a
existé avec des systèmes d'animation
comme du sable des décors déroulant
comme on a pu en voir au début du cinéma
une histoire noire qui ne manque pas
d'humour
une bulle politique où les petits ces
merveilles et les grands crus deviennent
des enfants